boudjellal
[Musique]
oui
de commencer à 1977 il ya eu des langues
d'oc de coupe uefa pas été fait en
continu j'ai fait beaucoup de
compétitions dans les
80 voilà je me mettais un ancien membre
de l'équipe de france à l'époque que
plus beau là maintenant j'ai 57 ans
voilà c'est plus du karaté vous la
condition physique le plaisir la
technique ma vie yogo youtube vient y
arrive c'est un vrai sport un art
martial en plus c'est à nous qu'il ya un
esprit il ya une discipline il ya des
règles à respecter
il ya du respect à avoir pour les autres
voilà c'est un peu la particularité des
sports de combat japonais
deux mamans ils tombent mort des chevaux
qui apaise contrairement aux apparences
parfois que ces sports n'excite pas du
tout parce que plus en plus on monte en
grade le pion puis on s'assagit vu ça je
trouve que c'est un sport qui apaise et
puis et puis on peut aussi transmettre
aux autres donc c'est un aspect qui
coûtait intéressant